and welcome to Hannity tonight a big
budget battle taking place on Capitol
Hill speaker Kevin McCarthy and
President Joe Biden have reached a
tentative deal on the debt ceiling not
all Republicans not all Democrats are on
board in fact many are very outraged
about the agreement now coming up we
have former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich he supports the deal and
Congressman Dan Bishop North Carolina
who does not they will join us and
debate the purported compromise but
here's what you need to know about the
99 page so-called fiscal responsibility
act including arguments on both sides
now first the name just so you know it
means nothing we already have over 31
trillion dollars in debt and that
massive tally continues to grow even
after this bill still small government
economists people like Steve Moore
support the bill calling it a step in
the right direction Republican
Congressman on the other hand chip Roy
is referring to it as a turd sandwich
the Washington Times meanwhile they
describe it as a win for the GOP all
while representative Nancy mace is
trashing the deal for normalizing record
spending with the president who can't
find his pants now some Republican
lawmakers they are infuriated that the
compromise maintains what is an
unacceptably high level of covet error
spending and you know repurposes nearly
100 billion dollars in spending instead
of making outright cuts to the budget
this is a bill that pushes any further
negotiations back until after the
presidential election which is a very
key point of contention many Republicans
wanted yet another negotiation before
next year's presidential election they
fear handing Democrats a blank check if
they keep the White House in 2024.
here's what some Republicans like about
the bill one it caps non-defense
spending growth by no more than one
percent in 2024 and 2025 too the bill
does claw back 28 billion dollars in
unspend coveted funds 3 officially
cancels Biden's student loan pause
repayments now restart at the end of the
summer but it doesn't end them for it
marginally expands work requirements for
certain social programs like food stamps
five funding to Biden's insane 80
billion dollar plan to double the size
of the IRS that will be cut by 1.4
billion dollars a year but a far cry
from the Republican bill that slashed
the program completely and according to
CNN another 20 billion will be
repurposed in 2024 and 2025 quote this
provision does not appear in the text of
the bill but another source familiar
with the deal said both sides have
agreed to that but that means best case
scenario is Biden's IRS expansion will
still have around 60 billion dollars to
work with as conservatives point out the
budget cuts are small not enough for
some Republicans remember their bill cut
4.8 trillion also the work requirements
feature a lot of exceptions and some
believe that the cuts are essentially
window dressing to a terrible bill now
other Republicans are for it the
Republicans passed the original bill
again that saved 4.8 trillion over 10
years according to Kevin McCarthy this
bill saves just over uh two trillion
dollars which is a record spending cut
now finally the bill also Cuts some red
tape around certain energy projects and
expedites a pipeline in West Virginia
that's good for the energy sector in
this country now of course Democrats
they are also livid about the provisions
you have the far left Sierra Club
calling it a bad deal for the country
you have Senator Tim Kaine attempting to
now torpedo the legislation in the U.S
Senate you have congresswoman Corey Bush
now accusing her fellow lawmakers of
quote taking food out of vulnerable
people's mouths needless to say
Democrats they're not happy with this
bill like some Republicans aren't take a
look we're being held hostage because I
am one of the people that has read all
100 pages of this bill and I have been
asking questions for three days and
there are things in this bill that I
would clearly not support will you vote
in favor
I'm still undecided because I know we
can't default I'm angry that we're in
this position so I have some serious
concerns about the Dale wolf and my team
and I are still reviewing it we just
received the text last night but one of
the major concerns is on non-defense
discretionary spending another major
problem is the Joe manchin pipeline that
we fought so hard to stop from being
built that is still a part of this bill
now no doubt many on both sides of the
aisle are either happy or unhappy about
the quote compromise even though the
bill is online for all to see and has
advanced through committee it is still
subject to change with amendments and
that complicates the agreement even more
and we have the so-called hard deadline
which is not a hard deadline which Janet
Yellen says is June the 5th we do know
do know one thing for sure a primary
holder of our debt is the Communist
Party of China and they do not fear they
do not respect this current president
and this administration because this
week they spit in our faces yet once
again and refused what was a polite
invitation for our country's top defense
officials to meet in Singapore they said
no go and this also comes as China's
neighbor North Korea well they just
launched a space vehicle in preparation
for the country's very first spy
satellite which reportedly ended in
Failure we could only hope it is now
more clear than ever under Biden we are
a train wreck both at home and abroad
China has declared a cold war against
our country and we are doing nothing to
stop it hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else